they tamed and rode and deployed in war
dragons hey everybody it's Charlie this
is gonna be george RR martin reading the
dragon binder chapter from winds of
winter so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos so i'll play this then
i'll break it down at the end of the
video enjoy this takes up right right
where to dance with dragons leaves off
it takes a little like like five minutes
after the end of a dance with dragons so
brace yourself you'll be right in the
middle of it here Victarion the noble
lady was a tub of a ship as fat and
wallowing as the noble ladies of the
green lands her holes were huge and
Victarion packed them with armed men
with her would sail the other lesser
prizes that the iron fleet had taken on
his long voyage to slavers Bay a lubber
e assortment of cogs great cogs Care
Act's and trading galleys salted here
and there with fishing boats it was a
fleet both fat and feeble promising much
in the way of wool and wines and other
trade goods and little in the way of
danger the carrion gave the command of
it to wolf one year the slavers made
shiver when they spy your sails rising
from the sea told him but once they see
you playing they will laugh at their
fears traitors and fishers that's all
you are any man can see that let them
get close as they like but keep your men
hidden below ducks until you're ready
then close and board them free the
slaves and feed the slavers to the sea
but take the ships we will have beat of
every halt to carry us back home home
wolf grinned a man will like the sound
of that Lord captain the ships first
then we break these yunkish men I the
iron victory was lashed alongside the
noble lady the two ships bound tight
with chains and grappling hooks a ladder
stretched between them the great cog was
much larger than the warship and sat
higher in the water all along the gun
walls the faces of the Ironborn peered
down watching as Victorian clapped wolf
one air on the shoulder and sent him
clambering up the ladder the sea was
smooth and still the sky
bright with stars Wolfe ordered the
ladder drawn up the chains cast off the
warship in the car parted ways in the
distance the rest of Victorians feigned
fleet was raising sail a ragged cheer
went up from the crew of the iron
victory and was answered in kind by the
men of the noble lady Victarion had
given Wolf his best fighters he envied
them they would be the first to strike a
blow the first to see that look of fear
in the foeman's eyes as he stood at the
prow of the iron victory watching one
airs merchant ships vanish one by one
and to the west the faces of the first
foe he'd ever slain came back to
Victorian Greyjoy he thought of his
first ship of his first woman a
restlessness was in him a hunger for the
dawn and the things this day would bring
death or glory I will drink my fill of
both today the sea stone chair should
have been his when Balon died but his
brother you're on it stolen it from him
just as he had stolen his wife many
years before he stole her and he soiled
her but he left it for me to Slater all
that was done and gone now though
Victarion would have his due at last I
have the horn and soon I will have the
woman a woman lovelier than the wife he
made me kill captain the voice belonged
to long water pike the oars men await
your pleasure three of them and strong
ones sended to my cabin
I want the priest as well the oarsmen
were all big one was a boy one a brute
one of bastards bastard the boy had been
rowing for less than a year the brute
420 they had names what victory and did
not know them one had come from
lamentation one from Sparrow Hulk one
from Spider kiss he could not be
expected to know the names of every
thrall who had ever pulled an oar in the
iron fleet show them the horn he
commanded when the three had been
ushered into his cabin mokoro brought it
forth and the dusky woman lifted up a
lantern to give them all look in a
shifting Lantern light the hell horn
seemed to rise and turn in the priests
hands like a serpent fighting to escape
mokoro was a man of monstrous size big
belly broad shouldered towering but even
in his grasp the horn look huge my
brother found this thing on valaria
Victarion so of the thralls
think how big the dragon must have been
to bear two of these upon his head
bigger than Veigar or more oxys bigger
than balerion the black dread he took
the horn from mokoro when ran his palm
along his curves at the Kingsmoot on old
wick one of Euron's mutes blew upon this
horn some of you will remember it was
not a sound that any man who heard it
will ever forget they say he died the
boy said him a blew the horn I the horn
was smoking after the mute had blisters
on his lips and the bird inked across
his chest was bleeding he died the next
day when they cut him open his lungs
were black the horn is cursed said the
bastards bastard
a dragon's horn from Valerius at
Victorian high it's cursed I never said
it wasn't he brushed his hand across one
of the red gold bands and the ancient
glyph seemed to sing beneath his
fingertips for half a heartbeat he
wanted nothing so much as to sound the
horn himself urine was a fool to give me
this it is a precious thing and powerful
with this I'll win the sea stone chair
and then the iron throne with this I'll
win the world clag Oran blew the horn
thrice and died for it he was the big as
any of you and strong as me so strong
that he could twist a man's head right
off his shoulders with only his bare
hands and yet to horn killed him it will
kill us too then said the boy Victarion
did not all forgive a Thrall for talking
out of turn but the boy was young no
more than 20 and assumed to die besides
he let it pass the mute sounded the horn
three times you three will sound that
only once might be you'll die might be
you won't omen die the iron fleet is
sailing into battle many on this very
ship will be dead before the Sun Goes
Down stabbed or slashed gutted drowned
burned alive only the gods know which of
us
still be here come tomorrow sound the
horn and live and I'll make freemen of
you one or two or all three
I'll give you wives a bit of land a ship
to sail thralls of your own men will
know your names
even you Lord captain as to bastards
bastard I I'll do it then and me said to
boy the brood crossed his arms and
nodded if it made the three feel braver
to believe they had a choice let them
cling to that Victarion kid little what
they believed they were only thralls you
will sail with me on iron victory he
told them but you will not join the
battle boy you're the youngest you'll
sound the horn first when the time comes
you will blow it long and loud they say
are strong blow the horn until you are
too weak to stand until the last bit of
breath has been squeezed from you until
your lungs are burning but the freedmen
hear you in marine slavers in Yong Chi
the ghosts in Astapor
let the monkey themselves at the
sound when it rolls across the isle of
cedars then past a horn along to the
next man do you hear me
do you know what to do the boy and the
bastard bastards tugged their forelocks
the brute might have done the same but
he was bald you may touch the horn then
go they left him one by one the three
thralls and then mokoro victorian would
not let him take the hill horn I will
keep it here with me until it's needed
as you command would you have me bleed
you victory and see is the dusky woman
by the wrist and pulled her to him she
will do it go pray to your red God light
your fire and tell me what you see
mokoros dark eyes seem to shine
I see dragons so the funny thing about
this is that Victarion
doesn't care anything about his men he
just really excited that he's finally
gonna get a one-up on your--on because
he's stolen everything from him he stole
the sea stone chair he stole one of his
wives that he himself later felt like he
had to kill so he's taken three
different men from his fleet he has
dragon binder and he's gonna have each
of
blow the horn once as hard as they can
because back at the Kingsmoot they all
watched one of Euron's mutes blow it
three times when they cut him open the
next day they found that his lungs had
blackened and the horn was still giving
off a little bit of smoke so I think
part of what Martin's implying is that
you have to be dragon seed in order to
blow the horn safely because it's called
dragon binder you use it to control
dragons even though that's not how
Victorians planning on using it when
Martens reading this chapter that's how
your on wants to eventually use it to
control Daenerys as Dragons so far we
haven't seen either of the really
notable magical horns on the TV show
dragon binder or the Horn of winter it's
always possible they could invoke some
of that during the final season but it
seems like they're not going to be doing
them the same way that they haven't done
Lady Stoneheart
dragon binder itself is actually carved
from a dragon horn with Valyrian glyphs
on it so the horn itself was literally
attached to a dragon at one point
Victarion is thinking to himself that
it's so big that the dragon that it had
belonged to must have been even bigger
than balerion the black dread the
biggest known dragon in history but you
have to remember that recorded history
doesn't go back that far they don't have
a lot of records from ancient Valyria so
it is totally possible that there were
ancient dragons even bigger than
balerion but no real evidence besides
dragon binder exists to prove that but
for the most part as martin says this is
picking up in the moments at the
beginning of winds of winter right
before the second siege of murine that
event on the TV show took place at the
very end of season six that's when we
saw Daenerys dragons burn some of the
wise masters ships then separately Theon
and Yara sailed in formed a pact with
Daenerys then they took the wise master
ships that were left over and added them
to their fleet so remains to be seen if
things go down in a similar way but
remember in the books Quentyn Martell
accidentally frees Daenerys dragons so
it's implied that they'll get out of the
pyramid and something similar will go
down albeit in a very different way the
only real update that Martin's given on
the winds of winter release date is that
he's stopped blogging so that he can
work faster like he isn't doing as many
public appearances he's already
confirmed that they're releasing fire
and blood later this year but it does
sound like Windsor winter won't be
released till next year when the TV
shows getting ready to drop or possibly
even later than that it's really hard to
tell and it's always a bad idea
to try and pinpoint winds a winter
release dates it usually leads to
disappointment so just leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below and I'll say congratulations to
the latest DVD giveaway winner Daniel
picket please private message me so I
can get your contact details there was a
new round in this video I'll just name a
new winner when I post new Game of
Thrones click here for that Cersei
Lannister teaser and click here for that
Arya Stark Valyrian dagger video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight